BRENDAN KENNY: Hi, this
is Brendan Kenny.
I'm an engineer with the
Google Maps Developer
Relations team.
Today, I wanted to share with
you a few simple tips on how
the Chrome developer tools can
make developing with the
Google Maps APIs a
whole lot easier.
Now, if you've never opened up
the dev tools before, you can
do so by coming up here to the
Wrench menu, dropping down to
Tools, and selecting
Developer Tools.
You can also use the really
handy keyboard shortcuts,
Command Option I on the Mac,
and Control Shift I
on Windows and Linux.
Now, once they're opened up,
you should see something
familiar if you've ever used the
developer tools on a lot
of the major browsers.
Over here on the left, we have
an outline of all the DOM
elements in the page.
And if we select one, on the
right, you'll see the matching
CSS rules and the styles they
apply to that element.
But we're not that interested
in that today.
Instead, I'd like to stop by the
network panel where, if we
load a map, we can see all the
files that had to be loaded in
order to put this page in
a map on the screen.
What's good about this is we
can look at any individual
file and see if there's some
kind of network problem, see
if it's too large or bloated,
and we need
to shrink that image.
We can also see timing
information to see how long it
took for the server
to respond.
And then finally, download
that file.
So that's pretty helpful.
But what we're most interested
in today is here in the
developer console.
Now, what the developer console
gives us is actually
an interactive JavaScript
execution environment.
What's more, it's the same
execution environment that the
page itself is running in.
What this means is that the
code that we write on our
page, and any code that we've
loaded, like the Google Maps
API, is actually code that
we can interact with
right now at runtime.
Now, since maps are such a
visual medium, this provides a
great way to tweak our code
and algorithms and see the
results instantly, as opposed
to going back to our source
code, making an edit, saving,
and then refreshing every time
we want to make a
small change.
Now, in order to take advantage
of this, we have to
make a slight change to our
source code so that everything
that we need is in the global
scope and we can find it right
here in the console.
So if we switch over, we can see
that this map is a pretty
typical "Hello, World" example
of the Maps API.
We start off with an options
object, which gives it a
default view and a map type.
We take that options object and
a DOM element, and we can
create our map itself.
Now, the problem here
is we're keeping a
reference to the map.
But we're declaring that
reference inside this function.
So as soon as this function is
over, this reference is gone.
Now instead, we can take that
reference and declare it
outside in the global scope.
And now, if we save and
return to our page.
Now, if we refresh and write
"map" here, you can actually
see that the console provides
us with an interactive
representation of
the map object.
You might even recognize some
of the Maps API here.
So just as I said, we can now
interact with this just as we
would in the code on the page.
So if I write map.getZoom, I
can see the current zoom.
But I can actually set
things as well.
So just as a really simple
example, map.setZoom5 gives us
a nice, zoomed out
view of Sydney.
Now, this actually brings up
one of the things that is
really handy just for setting
up even a basic map.
You want the perfect
view to start off.
So maybe you want to start
off looking at Japan.
So we find our nice view here.
We come back down
to the console.
And you see that things have
gotten kind of crowded with
these network errors
and warnings.
So one really nice thing you
can write is "clear." And
that'll actually clear
the console.
So I want to look at this
view every time I
want to open the map.
So I can actually ask the map,
what is the current view?
So map.getZoom tells
us level 10.
And I can do map.getCenter
to find out the center.
But that will return
a latlong object.
And I'll have to look at
it and interrogate it.
But what I can do to be extra
sneaky, I know there's a
toString method on here that
will give me a string
representation of the latitude
and longitude of the
center of the map.
So now, I can copy this, go back
to the source code, paste
it into the beginning.
And I know I need to change
my zoom to level 10.
And when I save this and then
refresh the page, you can see
that I'm now starting exactly
where I wanted to.
Let's look at a slightly
more advanced example.
Now here, we have the amazing
wireframe that my designer
gave me for our new site.
So I've taken that wireframe
and dropped it into the
background of this page.
And he's told me that a map
needs to go here in this
center area.
So I've re-structured the page
a bit, put a div there, and
dropped a map in it.
But as you can clearly see,
nothing is there.
So let's open up the dev tools
and try to figure out
what's going on.
The first thing we notice is
this JavaScript error-- cannot
set property position
of undefined.
Now, the problem is I never set
a property named position
at any point in my code, so that
seems a little bit odd.
If I dropped down this arrow
here, I can actually see a
stack trace of all the functions
that were called
that led to this error.
But once again, I see a bunch
of function names
that I don't recognize.
[? Nee ?] and [? To ?]
[? j.O ?] aren't functions
that I ever
wrote in my own code.
And the explanation for this can
be found here on the right
where you can see that
all these errors
took place in main.js.
That's a JavaScript file
that was loaded by the
Maps API, not by me.
Now, my first instinct
might be to go file a
bug on the Maps API.
After all, the error is
happening in their code.
But I have a sneaking suspicion
that the problem
actually lies in my own.
I started with known, good,
working code, the earlier
example, and added to it and
changed it until I could get
it to work in this design.
So it's possible I introduced
a bug somewhere in the steps
in between.
There are few ways we can
track down this problem.
One is the old fashioned brute
force method of starting with
a known, good code, and then
adding the new code line by
line, saving and refreshing
every time, until we finally
encounter the bug.
A somewhat better approach
would be to
use the console object.
Console is an object that lives
on the window in the
global scope and provides an
API so that your JavaScript
code can utilize the developer
console here just as if you
were sitting here
typing on it.
Now, one of the most helpful
methods that it provides is
the log method, which basically
just logs statements
to the developer console.
So it's just console.log
and some value.
So here's a string.
And there you go.
So let's switch over to the
source for this page.
And you can see things are
mostly the same here.
And so I'm going to guess that
maybe I changed something in
my options that caused
a problem.
So I'm just going to
add a console.log
statement here, my options.
And we save it, and come
back here, and refresh.
Now, we can see before this
error statement, I do indeed
have an object here.
And I can look.
And as we did before, we can see
that, well, OK, the center
look rights.
The map ID looks right.
And zoom looks right.
So maybe that's not the issue.
So let's switch back over
to our source code.
And here, we have the
log statement.
And now, we can add one
after map div and
make sure that's OK.
And one after map, and
But you can tell as this
scales to hundreds and
thousands of lines of code,
it's not really feasible
anymore to use console.log.
Log is great for
actual logging.
But if you have hundreds and
thousands of lines to go
through to find out where the
problem occurred, you really
haven't made your problem
any easier.
So let's get rid of this
console.log statement.
Go back to our page.
So the last approach I want to
take to solving this problem
lies in the scripts panel.
Now, the scripts panel has kind
of an intimidating UI.
And I think a common first
reaction to seeing it is, the
JavaScript problem you're
facing today isn't tough
enough to justify the time it'll
take to learn how to use
the scripts panel.
But it turns out the tools
available here are enough to
solve basically any JavaScript
problem.
So it's really worth at
least trying out.
Here on the left, you can see
all the JavaScript files that
were loaded to create
this page.
This can be a little confusing
at first, until you notice
that the top of each tree
has the domain listed.
So here, localhost is where I'm
hosting most of my files.
And mapgrid.html is
my main page.
So when I open it up, you can
see the full source of the
page, and then down
here, the actual
JavaScript that's executing.
Now, like the debuggers in many
languages, the scripts
panel provides a way to
set break points.
So if I click here on a line of
code, the JavaScript engine
will actually pause execution
when it reaches this line and
allow me to inspect the
state interactively.
Now, the problem here is, of
course, that the break point
is in the initialized function,
which is executed
when the page is first loaded.
But as long as we have the
developer tools open, we can
actually refresh the page, and
Chrome will remember our break
point and pause there.
So now, we've paused before
things have even started in
our initialized function.
And so now, we can take a
look at what's going on.
Up here in the top right, we
have the buttons that control
our experience during this
debugging session.
First, we have a
Resume button.
That just resumes execution
as if there
never was a break point.
We have a Step Over button, and
this will let us move from
line to line and actually see
how each line develops within
this function.
And then, we actually have a
Step Into button that will go
and dig down into any functions
that we encounter so
we can see what's going on in
those functions as well.
Now, in this case, we don't
really have any function calls
that we're interested in.
We have a latlong and map
constructors, but that's just
obfuscated code.
And then, we have actually the
selector for the map canvas
div, but that just digs
into jQuery code.
So in this case, we're only
going to be using the Step
Over button.
So below here, you can see all
the variables we're going to
be using within this function.
The map div objects, we're going
to be initializing down
here, and the myOptions
object, we're about to
initialize.
And if you're really brave,
you can see all the global
variables that are available
at this point.
The problem is there's
a whole lot of them.
Everything that's declared in
the window is listed here.
But if you scroll down to "M,"
you can see our lonely, little
map that we're going to
be constructing soon.
And we put it in the
global scope here.
But we're not that interested
in the global variables, so
let's collapse that.
And we can start looking
through this
code step by step.
So if we hit Step Over, we
execute this statement.
And the myOptions object
is now initialized.
And you can see, just as when
we logged it to the
console.log, everything
looks OK.
We have a center, and we have
the correct map type ID, and
the correct zoom.
So let's keep going.
In this next line, we use jQuery
to select the correct
map canvas div that
we're going to use
to create the map.
So if we execute that statement,
we can now see
something strange.
mapdiv is set to
[? e.fn.e.anet1 ?], which is
definitely not what
we'd expect.
We'd expect some kind of
representation of a DOM element.
Once again, our secret weapon
for figuring out what's going
on is the developer console.
Now, I could go over to the
developer console panel.
Or I could hit Escape and get
a mini one right here.
So I want to figure out what's
going on with mapdiv, so I'll
just log that and see
what's going on.
And it looks like I do have
the correct DOM element.
But it's inside of an array
for some reason.
So at this point, I would know
that this came back from the
jQuery function.
So I'd go and check
the jQuery docs.
And I'd remember that the jQuery
function doesn't return
the selected objects directly.
It actually creates a new
jQuery object with those
objects associated with it.
Now, this is great for jQuery
because it allows all the
really fun jQuery function
chaining that
you can do with jQuery.
The problem is the Maps API
expects a DOM element
directly, and not something
wrapped up in another object.
To fix the issue, I want to come
back to my source code.
And there's a couple of
ways you can do this.
But the easiest one, I find,
is just .get(0).
And since I know this is an ID
and there's only one of them,
"0" is the appropriate
index to use.
I save it, come back here.
And I can exit from dev tools.
And when I refresh the
page, there's my map.
And there's the basic
introduction to using the
Chrome developer tools with
the Google Maps APIs.
If you don't use any developer
tools today, you should really
try them out.
And I think you'll find your
life as a developer will
become considerably easier.
And you'll be able to
concentrate on problems that
actually matter.
If you'd like to know more,
you can visit this link.
And you can find a list of
all the commands and APIs
available, as well as further
screencasts that gives more
information into using
developer tools.